partita lo bambini umani e robot bambini
e un titolo un po diciamo
con due facce di fatto perché i bambini
e robot quindi quello che io cercherò di
fare oggi in questi minuti che ho a
disposizione e spiegarmi come stanno
assieme queste due cose perché in realtà
diciamo è un oscillazione
andare da una parte all'altra
no che ha mi ha accompagnato durante
tutta la mia vita accademica cioè studio
i bambini o costruisco io voglio solo un
ingegnere quindi diciamo nel mio cuore
cioè quello di costruire le cose però se
devo in questa vecchia diapositiva in
questa vecchia fotografia in cui sono
rappresentate quando ancora non mi tinge
i capelli di bianco che quello che ho
sulle spalle mio primogenito lo faccio
vedere perché questa fotografia è stata
ripresa in un laboratorio di
neurofisiologia del cnr dove allora
studiavo e studiavo cosa studiavo lo
sviluppo nei bambini
cercavo di capire come durante i primi
anni di vita il sistema visivo
acquisisce le capacità che poi abbiamo
da adulti quindi oscillazione bambino
adesso guardiamo dopo esce laiv non
serve una bella musica qualche anno dopo
io non sono più in questa diapositiva
però quel bimbetto ii e il mio
secondogenito che gioca con un robot non
gioca con una testa robotica di quelle
che abbiamo sviluppato durante questi
anni quindi è un pestato un po diciamo
questa caratterizzazione bambino robot è
stata un po una cosa che mi ha
accompagnato
lungo tutta la mia carriera fino ad oggi
fino ad arrivare a dove sono adesso non
ti aspetto qui è un po se riusciamo
tale si carichi ecco dove c'è questa
questa discrasia apparente da un lato
c'è un robot una pallina rossa e
dall'altro c'è un bambino che cerca di
afferrare un oggetto cos'è che accomuna
chi cerca di costruire un sistema
intelligente e chi cerca di studiare
come funziona il sistema intelligente è
possibile che queste due branche della
scienza trovino dei punti d'incontro è
possibile che si aiutano l'un l'altro
quali sono le cose che vengono fatte
dall 1 che possono aiutare l'altro in
maniera bidirezionale non solo in un
senso ecco quello che cercherò di fare
oggi in questi 12 35 minuti che mi sono
rimasti no è quello di raccontarvi
questo rispondendo sostanzialmente a tre
domande la prima è perché usare un robot
per capire l'intelligenza la seconda è
perché un robot troppo morfo posso usare
atto una serie di robot diversi da un
robot antropomorfo una terza è perché
uno buono un nuovo bambino cosa vuol
dire un robot bambino quindi cercherò di
andare attraverso questo velocemente
attraverso queste tre domande perché
usare un robot per
studiare l'intelligenza io faccio un
esempio molto semplice se voi avete
tutti noi abbiamo un orologio ho sempre
detto l'orologio come fate a sapere a
capire a studiare come funziona uno
certamente non è sufficiente che lo
sappiate usare neanche che vi leggete
con attenzione tutto il manuale d'uso
non è neanche sufficiente che io vidi a
un sacchettino con detto tutti i pezzi
di questo orologio quando si avete messi
bene sul tavolo in realtà non sapete
come funziona l'orologio per sapere come
funziona un orologio dovete sapere come
questi pezzettini si incastrano come
funzionano diciamo uno dell'altro lato
vede in qualche maniera capire a cosa
servono i singoli pezzi e come si
incassano l'orologio è un oggetto
complicato ma figuriamoci diciamo se ora
dovessimo prendere in considerazione un
corpo umano come facciamo con un corpo
ma certamente tutti siamo bravissimi a
imparare a usarlo giochiamo a tennis
faccia avuto una serie di cose ragioni a
mano lo studio dei pezzetti già diventa
un pochino più complicato perché
veramente certamente potete studiare a
pezzi cioè gli studi al cervello che
studia i muscoli che studia lo scheletro
che studia gli occhi a voi potete
studiarli a pezzetti però non potete
spaccare o meglio potete se volete
dividere un corpo in pezzetti però poi
vi sfido a invece di essere già con la
sveglia ricorderà la lombardia ma dei
problemi col corpo figuriamoci in realtà
per capire come funziona il cervello voi
o come funziona diciamo l'intelligenza
dovete provare a mettere assieme tutte
queste cose e provare a mettere assieme
le conoscenze che voi avete acquisito
per ogni singolo pezzetto è una cosa che
nella quale alla robotica può può dare
un aiuto
in realtà il concetto appunto del
costruire per capire se io riesco a
costruire qualcosa probabilmente
riescono anche a capire ho anche capito
come funziona non copiare l'oggetto ma
effettivamente capire perché funziona in
quel modo quindi non sapere come
funziona da quel particolare orologio ma
capire come posso immaginare una
macchina che misura il tempo quindi che
in questo concetto di tempo che poi io
posso realizzare con orologi digitali
complessive con tutta una serie di mezzi
però diciamo il concetto della misura
del tempo e il concetto
dell'intelligenza se vogliamo ovviamente
molto più complicato parlare un po
quello che volevo spiegare un po l'idea
di leonardo da vinci l'ho sentito citare
anche prima che studiava la natura e le
macchine diciamo che costruiva maschile
simili agli oggetti naturali perché
voleva capire come funzionavano e non
solamente la parte meccanica perché
quello che vedete il disegno della
scapigliata che vedete su questa su
questa figura nella maniera che aveva
leonardo per rappresentare le emozioni
il contenuto di saab oggi di semola
mente diciamo in ambito robotico quindi
studiare il corpo e la mente è un po
l'oggetto quindi quest'apparente
discrasia fra l'ingegnere il
neuroscienziato in realtà è solo
apparente sono due facce della stessa
medaglia
l'ingegnere si chiede ad esempio quali
sono i meccanismi che io devo realizzare
in un robot perché possa guidare la sua
madre il diavolo scienziato si chiede
quali sono i meccanismi che gli devo
movimento di una mano di un vino
entrambi si fanno esattamente la stessa
domanda 1 strumenti diversi per
rispondere alla stessa domanda
la possibilità di quindi un po l'idea no
del dell'uso del robot per capire
diciamo come funziona l'intelligenza
sostanzialmente per capire come mettere
a segno i pezzetti di questa ipotetica
teoria dell'intelligenza che nel corso
degli anni stiamo cercando di sviluppare
quindi posso studiare i pezzetti del
pazzo o uno per uno posso anche
immaginare quale la struttura del puzzle
quindi fare un'ipotesi sul quale quali
sono gli ingredienti e dove dovrò andare
a mettere qualcosa però alla fine di
tutto devo provare devo avere uno
strumento per vedere se questa idea in
questo caso che io mi sono costruito
diciamo studiando queste cose
effettivamente funziona sta tutto a
sieve quindi un po questo diciamo il
motivo prima domanda anno spero di aver
dato una risposta sufficientemente
esauriente perché una buon trovò morfo
seconda domanda voi aprite una qualsiasi
rivista scientifica trovate robot che
vanno nello spazio robot che vanno
sott'acqua robot che assegnano macchine
che aiutano il medico a fare interventi
chirurgici perché non scatenare la
fantasia e cercare di capire
l'intelligenza usando qualcuno di questi
di questi robot sono già lì pronti
perché faticare tanto ma perché in
realtà quello che noi vorremmo fare
oltre che capire e studiare
l'intelligenza il nostro obiettivo
tecnologico è anche quello di rendere la
tecnologia un pochino più umana
umanizzare un po la tecnologia io in
mano dei telecomandi in tasca un altro
un telefonino una tastiera viviamo in un
mondo che è fatto di tastiere vogliamo
cercare di andare oltre ed è una delle
cose quest idea delle pareti gare di a
si qui a parlare come facciamo uscire
beh dobbiamo cercare di guardare in
direzioni diverse
uscire da queste idee hanno religiosa
dell'ingegnere che prende i pezzetti
dimettersi perché perché qui diciamo
siamo arrivati un pochino al limite non
possiamo fare dei cellulari più
complicati di quelli che sono quelli che
abbiamo adesso che non sapremo usarli
non potremo usare questo non è solamente
per i sinistri quei capelli e la barba
bianca non manca peraltro quindi l'idea
che noi vorremmo quello che vorremmo
riuscire a fare è di sviluppare dei
robot che siano in grado di comportarsi
come se fossero umani noi vecchi sogni
di
alberto sordi nel film io e caterina
in pratica diciamo alla metafora che
tutti quanti abbiamo nella mente quando
pensiamo robot cioè di immaginare di un
robot che dentro abbia un omino che si
comporta esattamente come se dentro ci
sono solo minimo questa cosa qui
purtroppo è ancora fantascienza
ovviamente come lo sappiamo tutti però
abbiamo fatto dei passi avanti non è uno
di questi è proprio l'aver scoperto
attraverso studi di neuroscienza no che
il corpo umano che il robot in qualche
maniera se c'è altro pò morfo ha dei
vantaggi ma quindi asimov quando pensava
ai suoi robot col cervello posytron ico
in realtà aveva ragione ma perché aveva
ragione quali sono adesso i motivi per i
quali possiamo dire che
aveva ragione
un altro esempio io diciamo prendetevi
un cellulare
ciascuno di voi è un cellulare intascano
pensate all'immagine immaginate diciamo
per usare un cellulare quello che voi
dovete fare è leggervi un manuale o
comunque avere qualcuno che vi spiega
come funziona e pensate diciamo al fatto
che un cellulare come quello che abbiamo
in tasca a quello che intasca io a un
manuale di 190 pagine
perché vi sto raccontando parte solo 10
per effettivamente usarlo come deriva
perché vi sto raccontando questo perché
la domanda che uno si può fare ma perché
quando io collaboro con qualcuno o
lavori sembra qualcun altro o prima di
lavorare siamo a qualcuno non devo
leggere il suo manuale
pensate un po se dovessi leggere il
manuale d'uso di un essere umano e io
dovrei cominciare a segnare mood di
pezzetti intanto perché siamo più
complicati dove dovrei mettere nel
mucchio buche fino a trasformare uno
minus a sebastiano trafitto dalle frecce
quindi va al di là di questo pensate il
manuale che viene fuori dalle sale un
oggetto di questo tipo diecimila pagine
per il maschietto poi c'è quello per le
femminucce che dall'altra diecimila paia
di in parti uguali ma con
distribuzione di contenuti diversi
quindi perché non abbiamo il manuale per
collaborare con gli altri ma
sostanzialmente perché è proprio il
fatto di essere nostro essere umani che
ci consente di interagire con gli altri
senza avere un annuali per che
implicitamente usiamo il nostro stesso
corpo come manuale degli altri
facciamo l'ipotesi che la persona con la
quale lavoriamo abbia lo stesso manuale
d'uso nostro che conosciamo benissimo
adesso siamo sviluppati noi quindi
quello di dice avere una cosa che
abbiamo nella nostra mente quindi l'idea
che la forma antropomorfa non è solo
importante perché erano bocca lavora con
noi deve usare il martello prender le
forbici video aver delle mani come le
nostre ma deve anche muoversi come ci
muoviamo come ci muoviamo noi non è
indifferente se io vi faccio vedere
questo filmino di
un signore che si muove solamente con
dei pallini io riesco a darvi l'idea di
diciamo voi avete l'idea vedete
alluminio che si muove di chiesa è il
movimento che è importante quindi questa
parte diciamo che vi consente di fare
tutta una serie di cose come capire
diciamo se il danzatore e un maschio o
una femminuccia quindi quello che noi
sappiamo dalle neuroscienze che per fare
delle cose noi dobbiamo essere in grado
per capire le cose che fanno gli altri
devono essere in grado anche di farle
per cui il violinista che ascolta un
suono di un violino lo interpreta in
modo diverso rispetto a chi lo ascolta
ma non sa suonare
perché diciamoci aggiunge tutta questa
sua conoscenza motoria come diceva italo
calvino sostanzialmente la nostra
immaginazione non può che essere
antropomorfa noi quando immaginiamo
pensiamo sempre come se fossero e questa
cosa è fondamentale anche per
trasmettere delle emozioni non solamente
per capire cosa uno sta facendo e quando
agisce per cui diciamo la passione di un
bacio come in questo caso con la
tenerezza e la gioia no perché la
bimbetta che ha preso questa tenere
vuole condividere questa gioia col
fratellino un fratellino che in realtà
sbaglia e non ha capito nulla della
tenerezza però il meccanismo che diciamo
la parte meccanica che gli interessare
spesso il cane un po questa idea quindi
perché un robot antropomorfo nola
l'ultima parte della domandano perché un
robot antropomorfo bambino che per me
diciamo e la cosa forse più interessante
cosa aggiunge il fatto di studiare un
bimbo a questo diciamo insieme di cose
che vi ho raccontato sostanzialmente
perché se voi immaginate ad un sistema
complesso come nostro non è sufficiente
capire come funziona il sistema ma
dovete anche capire come il sistema
viene costruito e vi faccio un altro
esempio se vi faccio vedere questo
grattacielo noi vi chiedessi come fate a
costruire una copia di questo
grattacielo e quindi capire come è fatto
se io anche vivessi tutti i progetti
fino all'ultima vite che serve per
chiudere l'ultima porta voi non sareste
in grado di farlo perché perché per
costruire questo oggetto sono state
necessarie dell'infrastruttura nel group
on the g cose di questo che alla fine
non ci sono più non sapete come è stato
costruito sapete come l'oggetto ma non
sapete lo è stato costruito ed è questo
che un'altra ed è questo che manca
diciamo perché il cervello banalmente
non è una bicicletta non potete dire
prima costruisco il cervello e poi vado
a studiare come funziona il cervello si
auto costruisce
l'intelligenza è sempre in evoluzione e
ancora di più no vi dico che in realtà è
proprio questo essere sempre in
costruzione che è la caratteristica
principale dell'intelligenza umana
quindi studiare lo sviluppo è
esattamente quello che vi consente di
capire come è possibile
costruire una mente e dall'altra parte
costruire dei robot bambini vi consente
di capire se effettivamente quello che
immaginate è un'ipotesi corretta se
possiamo capire come diventiamo noi
intelligenti quindi è questa duplice
consono quindi il robot bambino in
realtà come dicevo all'inizio è studiare
lo sviluppo dell'intelligenza per capire
come si costruisce una mente robot
antropomorfo bambino quindi detto questo
diciamo al di là delle tre domande a cui
ho dato una risposta brevissima vediamo
qualche robot perché altrimenti oramai
ho finito il tempo non vi farò vedere un
po di robot proprio perché diciamo è
importante qui è un po un'evoluzione
diciamo dal robot i primi robot che
abbiamo fatto nel 96 il secondo l'ultimo
che è quello un po più noto no in cui
abbiamo sviluppato tutta una serie di
motori è un oggetto che adesso viene
utilizzato in diverse parti del mondo
abbiamo un robot come questo che diciamo
costruito in italia ora diciamo lo usano
i giapponesi coreani quindi voglio dire
un po di orgoglio nazionale lastre rai e
cosa e cosa insegnano a questo robot ma
sostanzialmente insegnavo cose come
interagire con gli oggetti insegniamo
come inter come toccare gli oggetti e
soffice wei rigido lo puoi afferrare
oppure non lo puoi afferrare un po
esplorare il mondo che è quello che
fanno i bambini in fondo oppure diciamo
un'altra cosa che possiamo fargli fare è
cercare di capire quali sono gli effetti
delle proprie azioni cioè spingono un
oggetto e guardo cosa succede
le tre leggi di asimov della robotica in
realtà dietro anno quest'idea capire
l'effetto delle proprie azioni che è uno
degli aspetti principali oppure diciamo
possiamo far sì che sia in grado di
imparare dagli altri
parada gli altri che fanno vedere come
fare se vedere a un bimbo come costruire
un oggetto in questo caso nazione molto
semplice e in cui viene il robot diciamo
impara in questo caso un po per questo
particolare esperimento in maniera un po
diciamo scimmiesco se vogliamo ma il tar
a fare le azioni quindi cerchiamo di
ripercorrere diversi oppure a
socializzare qui è un'altra serie di
esperimenti in cui cerchiamo di capire
quali sono i meccanismi che fanno
collaborare le persone no qual è il
meccanismo che trasforma un semplice
gesto in un gesto che provoca la
reazione di qualcun altro no quindi il
robot che gioca con delle persone il
robot cambiamo certi parametri per
vedere quali sono quelli importanti per
far giocare quindi volevo farvi vedere
solo il video più importante poi lo
sulla destra quelli un po più grande e
vediamo se riesco
ecco questa qui vedete un il
comportamento di un robot del robot che
sembra che sia esausto nome si butta per
terra
in realtà questa è una vostra
interpretazione perché quello che è
successo di che si era staccata la spina
quindi tutto quello che era successo e
nel vostro cervello che ci ha messo
dentro le cose intelligenti ritornare al
discorso di alto profilo che ricevuto le
conclusioni allora cosa facciamo noi
studiamo queste cose per capire meglio
noi stessi un valore scientifico
costruiamo queste cose per sviluppare
nuova tecnologia e la terza cosa che
voglio citare perché è fondamentale
utilizziamo queste cose per sviluppare
dispositivi di riabilitazione
dispositivi che aiutano bambini che
hanno problemi di disabilità ad esempio
visive e motorie e la cosa che ho
segnato in giallo e il messaggio
importante soprattutto che sono molti
ragazzi
immaginate che il mondo sia un mondo di
disciplinare diventate esperti di una
cosa perché quello è fondamentale però
tenete le orecchie aperte per quello che
dicono gli altri perché altrimenti
queste cose non si mescolano non si
mette un assieme e chiudo
quest'ultimissima snai con la
definizione bellissima secondo mike ha
dato francesco cevasco di ai club quando
ha scritto sul corriere che è l'umanoide
capace di apprendere che potrebbe
diventare un sereno compagno di viaggio
nel tempo che non ha ancora avuto luogo
quel domani in cui la scienza non ci
farà più paura io spero che parte di
questo mio discorso di abbia un pochino
infuso questa fiducia della scienza e
della tecnologia che un posto andando
via e con questo vi ringrazio grazie